do you hear about that lady that got
acquired by nestle for selling queefs
that's the next frontier dude
that actually is though yeah i'm
surprised i mean maybe someone's already
doing that but
did you guys hear it going into my
vagina
that's definitely gonna be gonna be the
next thing yeah blowing the air out the
front yeah you could sell those for a
premium probably
no free queefs
we gotta do a shirt with that is your
instagram discover page do you ever get
the random like fitness
accounts yes all the time yeah whenever
i see a yoga person man or woman
whenever they i get like a random post
of them like grabbing their ankles like
head into their ass i always imagine
like clicking on that video and they're
like this is how i learned how to suck
my own dick
first i started by getting really nimble
it took me about two months step one in
eating my own ass
[Laughter]
dude my instagram explorer page is like
a cesspool oh yeah i think i told you
this but they just turned up yeah they
just turned up the knob in like
trashiness together oh yeah to get me a
click you know what i'm saying it's just
it's just all like tabloid [ __ ]
like looking at it now it's just like
oh it's the worst it makes me feel like
sick what kim kardashian like you know
i'm not laying there and then it's a
screenshot of
scott disick's comment on it
i'm sick yeah
no no dude you care you care dude you
definitely care i mean i clicked on it
scott disick what do you say
so damn where's the tripod
you